thought maybe we shouldn't touch very  you know very seriously because it it's  not not a very pleasant topic for anyone  involved i've i you know better than me  but even i from from my long association  with gusty i've heard some stories and  uh i think people in general have had  their issues with the  with the shah bund  uh and uh  yeah the  if you have the option uh as georg  clearly does of playing  uh of playing for his uh sort of  [Music]  the the country of his birth potentially  you can you can see why he's doing that  uh yeah and also we should mention one  thing yeah that now there is a new  generation coming in german chess yeah